The Landscape Tools Unreal Engine provides allow you to modify your landscapes right inside of the editor and can be used to create landscapes of any size.
Let's go ahead and take a look at how we use this tool in the editor now.
So from this blank menu, I'm going to come up here to my selection mode and go down to Landscape.
This is going to open up our Landscape tool. The Landscape tool is set up into three different kind of sub-tools.
There is the Manage mode, which helps us manage the size, location, and scale of our landscapes.
So right now what I'm going to do is set this to 31 by 31 and hit Create.
Now once I do that, you're going to see that my landscape is added to the world and then my tool is set to Sculpt.
And Sculpt allows us to actually sculpt our landscape.
As you can see here, I can use the various tools to affect the look of our landscape.
We also have the ability to change the brush size and its fall-off as well as its strength to help us further refine the look and the feel of the landscape.
Over on Paint, you have the ability to actually paint the surface of the landscape.
Now this current material landscape has on it automatically adjust its look based on the slope of the landscape.
But if we wanted to paint individual layers that represent grass, rocks, and things of that nature, we could do that right on the surface here using the Paint tool.
The Manage mode of our landscape actually allows us, if we come here to our Import, we can actually export this as a height map.
So that we can export or import a height map that was made in a third-party program into Unreal so that we can use that as a basis to work on.
Or we can export it out into another application to tidy up a little bit and then bring that back into Unreal Engine 5.
Now the landscape does have a few limitations that you should be made aware of.
For example, the landscape's tessellation is at the maximum amount that it can be.
So if we come in here and we look at this from the Wireframe mode, a landscape can never get more dense than it currently is.
I do believe the current is 1 meter per centimeter.
You can enable Nanite on your landscape.
And if you're dealing with a massive open world, I highly recommend that you do this so that you get the performance of Nanite on your landscape.
To do this, all you need to do is select your landscape and then come down to our Nanite and then just enable the Nanite settings and then build your data.
Once you do that, you will then have a landscape.
And if we come over here real quick, we can actually see some of that Nanite tessellation on this right there.
So there's some of that Nanite tessellation coming through.
And if we come here to our Lit and our Nanite visualization and go Overview, you can see here we are using Nanite on our terrain.
So that's how we are getting some of this cool offset.
But just go back to Lit mode and I'm going to go over to our Wireframe.
It is not actually, you know, again, increasing the regular tessellation of our landscape.
It's just increasing the visual density of it, giving us this look.
So remember that we can't actually increase the tessellation of our landscape.
If we want something to have some more detail, we're either going to need to add static meshes or work with displacement and Nanite tessellation in order to get that look that we're going for.